luisa tiene un negocio de podado de
césped ella quiere medir la tasa a la
cual incrementan el volumen de
combustible usado y el área que poda
cuál será la unidad apropiada para el
propósito de luisa vamos a volver a leer
esto subrayando los datos importantes
ella quiere medir la tasa a la cual
incrementan el volumen de combustible
usado y el área que poda así que sus
unidades deberán ser algo así como
volumen sobre área ella quiere medir
como incrementa el volumen de
combustible usado y el área que poda así
que las unidades deben ser volumen sobre
áreas veamos cuáles de estas unidades
nos dan volumen sobre áreas
esta unidad de litros de aquí es
definitivamente unidad de volumen pero
esta unidad de aquí no es de área es de
distancia si fueran kilómetros cuadrados
entonces sí sería área así que
descartamos esta opción centímetros por
kilómetro bueno esta y estas son
unidades de distancia no de volumen
sobre área así que también descartamos
esta opción centímetros por kilómetro
cuadrado un centímetro es una unidad de
distancia kilómetro cuadrado es una
unidad de área pero nosotros buscamos
volumen por área así que también
descartamos esta opción
ahora tenemos litros por kilómetro
cuadrado ésta luce bien ya que litros es
una unidad de volumen y sin duda
kilómetro cuadrado es una unidad de área
y esta no es la única combinación que
pudo habernos funcionado pero de las
opciones que nos muestran aquí es la
única que funciona si nos hubieran dicho
una pinta por pie cuadrado o metro
cúbico por kilo
al cuadrado también nos habría dado
volumen por área o volumen sobre área
pero esta es la mejor opción de las que
nos muestran vamos a ver otro problema
la nieve se acumula afuera de la casa de
cameron él recibe medir la tasa a la
cual se incrementa la altura de la
acumulación de nieve con respecto al
tiempo cuál será la unidad apropiada
para el propósito de cameron como
siempre pausa en el vídeo para tratar de
resolver esto por su cuenta así que se
quiere medir la tasa a la cual se
incrementa la altura con respecto al
tiempo así que en la unidad que buscamos
es distancia o mejor dicho longitud por
tiempo veamos las opciones aquí tenemos
horas por metro y esto es tiempo por
longitud y lo que buscamos es justo lo
contrario así que descartamos esta
opción la siguiente litros por minuto
esto es volumen por unidad de tiempo
pero buscamos longitud por unidad de
tiempo así que esta otra opción tampoco
nos sirve las siguientes minutos por
litro
es tiempo por volumen así que tampoco es
la que buscamos la última es metro que
es longitud por hora que es unidad de
tiempo metros por hora
esto es longitud y esto es tiempo y
siempre es bueno regresar al inicio y
considerar nuestra respuesta en el
contexto original él decide medir la
tasa a la cual se incrementa la altura
de la acumulación de nieve con respecto
al tiempo si alguien dijera bueno es que
la altura de esa acumulación de nieve
está aumentando 5 metros por hora aunque
sería demasiado para la nieve no sé
digamos que aumenta medio metro por hora
aunque sigue siendo bastante rápido esta
unidad tiene sentido en nuestra mente ya
que cada hora voy a tener medio metro
más de nieve si alguien nos dijera bueno
es que la nieve allá afuera se está
incrementando en medio litro por minuto
bueno eso quizá podría ser el volumen de
nieve
pero no nos estaría dando la altura de
la acumulación con respecto al tiempo
así que la altura con respecto al tiempo
es longitud por tiempo por lo que esta
es nuestra opción correcta